[Musique]
la légende du basket français Florent
Piétrus est venu saluer les performances
du club Rambouillet sport Basket le club
a organisé son premier concours All-Star
Game au gymnase Jean-Claude Foulon un
événement auquel le sportif s'est rendu
pour soutenir les joueurs et signer
quelques autographes un plaisir les
trois écoles du valibout vont se
regrouper en un seul groupe scolaire
l'école maternelle Louise-Michel sera
démoli et fusionnera avec l'école
maternelle Daniel Casanova l'école sera
réhabilitée et agrandi passant de 5 à 8
classes et connaîtra de nombreux
aménagements extérieurs l'école
élémentaire Pierre Brossolette connaîtra
aussi quelques changements comme la
création d'une infirmerie ou d'un local
de stockage le pôle éducatif devrait
être livré en juillet 2025 le 3 décembre
dernier l'hôpital André Mignot de
Versailles a été paralysé par une
cyber-attaque un événement qui avait
complètement désorganisé l'établissement
17 jours après l'heure est à la
reconstruction l'hôpital tourne
actuellement à 60% de sa capacité les
urgences notamment accueillent sans
passage contre 17 en temps normal
l'établissement pourrait prendre
plusieurs semaines avant de retrouver un
fonctionnement normal l'enquête est
toujours en cours concernant les auteurs
de l'attaque le maire de Buchelay Paul
Martinez à démissionné de ses fonctions
après 15 ans à la tête de la commune il
souhaite se consacrer pleinement à son
poste de Directeur Général des Services
d'une agglomération de Seine-Maritime il
a cédé son fauteuil à son premier
adjoint Stéphane Tremblay en attendant
de nouvelles élections en février
prochain le professeur Olivier
Saint-Lary médecin généraliste installé
dans les Yvelines et enseignant en
médecine générale à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a
été réélu à la présidence du collège
national des généralistes enseignants il
est à sa tête depuis 2020 enfin c'est
les derniers jours pour s'inscrire au
festival du court-métrage des clés du
cinéma il ne reste que jusqu'au 31
décembre pour les réalisateurs débutants
ou expérimentés qui souhaiteraient
envoyer leurs films l'édition se tiendra
le 12 mars prochain à l'espace Philippe
Noiret pour postuler envoyer votre film
à l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran